this vax policy that canada has gone uh
which is clearly ushered in by this
great reset situation uh it has leaked
all over it's not just the netherlands
that's having problems and it's not just
the united states that's having problems
and it's not just canada that's having
problems and much more this has happened
all across the world uh you might have
heard of serbian tennis player a certain
serbian tennis player uh novak djokovic
who was banned uh quite often from many
different tournaments during kovid and
nobody really knew why he didn't want to
get vacs t again like many of these nba
players who didn't want to get vast or
some of the other professional athletes
these are usually young guys in their
20s and 30s who are at the peak of
physical health they just oddly didn't
want an experimental experimental
vaccine to be injected into them so he
was getting banned from tournaments left
and right well now john mcenroe you guys
know john mcenroe even if you're not a
tennis person legendary tennis player
john mcenroe and now broadcaster uh john
mcenroe he went off on the usa in
australia because they're not allowing
djokovic to play because he's unboxed
but now there's the uncertainty it's not
just the majors unfortunately for him
john it's
any tennis server where is he going to
play next
and be able to play in north well i hope
this is
open
it's a great moment these politicians
are getting the way uh too much they did
it in australia let's let the guy come
in and play the in the us i mean come on
this is ridiculous
but
i don't make those decisions i hope that
someone makes the right one and allows
him to play
so do you think any of this has to do
with logic or reason or anything else
djokovic right there who's basically
been the best tennis player probably for
like in the world probably for about a
decade young guy right there incredible
athlete incredible athlete peak physical
condition right to be a tennis player at
that level he's not sick and even if he
was sick you're allowed to make choices
over your body i thought it was my body
my choice right but for some reason the
united states and australia won't let
him play in these tournaments john
mcenroe gets it but we need more and
more people to get it